[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferris welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferris show and it is
my pleasure today to have wiby Britain
PhD on the podcast she is a clinical
psychologist and associate professor of
Psychiatry and human behavior at Brown
University Medical School and the
director of Brown's clinical and
effective Neuroscience laboratory and
that is a effective with an a her
clinical Neuroscience research
investigates the effects of
contemplative practices I.E meditation
or certainly one example being
meditation on the brain and body in the
treatment of mood disorders trauma and
other conditions she is especially
interested in which practices are best
or worst suited for which types of
people or conditions and why she is
probably best known for her research on
adverse effects why they happen and how
to mitigate them and we'll be doing a
very deep dive on this certainly Dr
Britain is the founder of cheetah house
as in the large and very fast cat
cheetah house a nonprofit organization
that provides evidence-based information
and support for meditators in distress
as well as meditation safety trainings
to Providers and organizations you can
find cheetah house on Twitter at cheetah
house org Facebook you can find at
cheetah house.org and on Instagram at
cheetah. housee Dr Brittain thank you
for making the time today nice to see
you thank you so much for having me
there are many reasons that I wanted to
have a conversation with you and one
certainly was due to my own experience
at a silent Retreat and having a
flooding of traumatic memories and
everything that that led to it was
overwhelming to an extent that I could
not have imagined and certainly had not
been prepared for secondly is a mutual
acquaintance I won't mention his name
because he is one of the more private
people in the world so I would always
want to double check had suggested that
we talk because there might be some
mapping or some similarities at least
between meditation related Adverse
Events and how symptoms present some of
the dissociation Etc that you can
observe in some people and some of the
adverse effects that you can see some
persistent effects after psychedelic use
So eventually we'll get to that but
let's start at the beginning or at least
with the Genesis story of sorts how did
you first become interested in
meditation like many people I had a life
crisis that precipitated the need for
something really different in my
life one of my childhood friends
committed suicide when I was in college
the summer between my Junior and Senior
year and it was devastating and
completely disregulated to
see a person just disappear from the
world like that just it wasn't in my
repertoire of possibilities that
somebody could just not be there anymore
so I had you know probably diagnosable
PTSD at that point and I really didn't
want to take medication I was only
and my dad sent me a path with heart by
Jack cornfield and that became my Bible
for the next probably decade and so for
those of you who don't know uh Jack
horfield is a very famous meditation
teacher and he's written many books and
this particular
one like many of them start off with
just what the mind can do and how to
work with it and it just you know it was
very practical a practical way to
manage all of the emotions that we're
having and it was great because it was
allowing them to be there too you know
it was like it wasn't suppressing them
ironically that book that particular
book that he wrote I only got about
halfway through it because there was
this the whole second half I just like
could not relate to because it was like
the spiritual roller coaster and like
Kundalini Awakenings and I was like I
don't know what that is so I'll just put
that down just take what you need
whatever and then that came back fast
forward 15 years was like oh right that
second half of that book let me go back
and read that but I'm getting ahead of
myself so going into graduate school I
was also very very interested in
Consciousness always and always
interested
in just what are we doing here you know
what is what's going on and what's
looking out of my eyes and like just
very curious and so that was already
happening and then I had
this this experience and it kind of
culminated in my graduate career looking
at alter States Of Consciousness in a
clinical psychology program at the
University of Arizona which happens to
be at the time the only place in the
world that had a Consciousness study
center so I was doing that and actually
my sort of professional life I actually
studied near-death experiences for my
Master's thesis and my own personal
trauma and
meditation practice was something I was
doing on my personal time it was not
part of my scholarship but I think at
some point during graduate school like
those two lives were so divided that I
needed to combine them just to be like
an integrated human being and so for my
dissertation I did a study on the
effects of mindfulness training on sleep
I was working in a sleep lab and and
sleep is you know it's it's illegal
alter State of Consciousness and it's
linked with every type of possible
health issue and so if you want to study
Altered States Of Consciousness it's a
good one to study because it's you know
you're not going to have it's not like
psychedelics that get banned everyone
does it happens every day hard to band
sleep yeah so it was a good one to
choose at the time this is two around
2000 there really wasn't great research
a lot of the
meditation research was on self-reports
there wasn't a lot of brain data
available and so I was going to be one
of the first people to record overnight
sleep polysomnography so this is
brain-based sleep and prove that
meditation was improving sleep because
of course it was I mean it's it's
relaxing you know Etc so that was my
dissertation and I spent like 200 nights
watching people sleep and at the end of
of the
day the hypothesis was not at all what I
expected so we actually found that no
matter how you measure the measured
arousal cortical arousal brain arousal
meditation was associated with
increasing it not decreasing it so it
was causing insomnia in
people and we looked at percentage of
slow wave sleep that went down we went
looked at how fast the brain waves were
those went up and the correlation was
with the amount of practice was 08 so
like no matter where you went there it
was and so and this is my first
confession is that I didn't publish the
data because I was like oh this is the
wrong you know I was like an evangelist
for meditation cuz I this is something
that had really helped me and I really
wanted to like use my science and my
position as a scientist to promote this
thing and so I didn't publish the data
and at some point when I was coming I
came to Brown to do my
residency couple years later I was on a
Meditation Retreat and I mentioned the
data that I had found which is basically
that it was causing cortical arousal
and insomnia and the meditation teacher
sort of chastised me and said I don't
know why all you you know clinical
psychologists are always trying to make
meditation into a relaxation
technique everyone knows that if you
meditate enough you stop
sleeping and I was like what bulletin
you know yeah and so that was kind of
like a wakeup call
literally and I thought okay well what
other assumptions are we
making I was
definitely pretty emblematic of a lot of
people who go into meditation research
or or the average meditator which is
like I didn't really know my Buddhism I
didn't really know my history I just
kind of you know signed up for whatever
was around and believed everything that
people said and the way that it was
marketed as a as a sort of health
promotion tonic I believed all that and
I didn't do my homework which is pretty
terrible as a meditation researcher and
so I was like okay like looks like I
need to do some history homework and
really look at the background of What
kinds of assumptions we're making as
Health Providers and like really look at
the translation process of how these
practices like where they came from what
kinds of changes they made what was the
journey like to get here into you know
to the west and really unpack that
process and then the second question was
what other little nuggets of of
knowledge do these meditation teachers
have that they're not telling us and I
and there's a followon part of the story
which is when I came to Brown to do my
clinical residency you have to do a year
of internship to see clients basically
to get your license I worked at an
impatient psychiatric hospital and
during that one year there were two
yogis who came off
Retreat completely
psychotic and I thought like wow two in
one year is it's kind of a lot seemed
like a lot to me so I went back to the
same teacher and I said well have you
ever seen this before and I remember
like distinctly that there was no actual
verbal reaction but there was this look
of like oh
[__] and I was like oh oh wow like there
is a story here like there is a
knowledge that this can happen and
meditation teachers are sitting on this
just a ton of information that needs to
be mined and as a meditation researcher
I was like like okay we need to start
asking these questions so that whole
story is the beginning of the varieties
of contemplative
experience study which was probably the
the simplest study that I've ever done
the hardest with simplest and that it
was basically just going to meditation
centers and teachers and saying what
types of challenges have you observed in
your
students how do you make sense of them
like what what are they how do you
interpret them and then very practically
what do you do about them so like very
straightforward set of questions and
yeah that took 10 years it's 3,000 pages
of qualitative data and I I don't even
know how many papers we've written we're
still writing papers based on that data
I think we're like over 10 now so it's
it's
really just a wormhole which we're going
to go down together oh we are we are
going to go arm and- arm down the
Wormhole so let me pause for a second I
want to make a promise to folks and I'll
give you a heads up also we will come
back to the near-death experiences I'm
going to leave that as a Scooby snack at
the end for people so I do I do want to
talk about
that however I want to dig into the
sleep for one
second if people stop sleeping period
full stop eventually they die right so
the
restorative functions of sleep I mean as
it is still poorly understood but are
critical to human functioning and
survival
so how would you explain if it is indeed
true that if people meditate enough they
kind of stop sleeping or they start
sleeping very minimally how would you
explain that is it that the meditation
practice itself provokes a state that is
restorative and
therefore the sleep is less necessary
or is there something else that you
would put as the front runner for
explaining that we can point readers to
various papers there is a paper that I
called Awakening is not a
metaphor I had to fight hard to keep
that that's pretty good that's pretty
good it's a review of different studies
across different types of methodologies
looking at how meditation
affects the awake Sleep System mhm it's
not as straightforward as like you stop
sleeping or you sleep less it's you know
it's going to be dependent on many
factors and I will say that in the study
that I was just talking about my
dissertation study we found a
non-monotonic nonlinear relationship so
people who are meditating less than half
an
hour and less than every day they
actually had an an increase in Sleep
Quality but people who are meditating
more than that that's when it sort of
Switched and turned into they were prone
to being more awake more insomnia more
cortical arousal so it's a sort of
biphasic nonlinear relationship M so
just a recap it it does not it's not
going to give you
insomnia probably automatically yeah
yeah because when we talk about
meditation it's like oh you do
meditation it's kind of like oh you do
sports or you do exercise it's like well
there a million different parameters and
types and so on right and and I think
you know one of the other papers that I
wrote which is called can mindfulness be
too much of a good thing introduces this
idea
of a small amount or an optimal amount
can do exactly what the you know the
hype and the promotions and the
advertising says like a lot of there is
a lot of Truth in the
advertising and the
positive report
but there's also there's another side of
the story which often comes with sort of
higher doses so one of the ways to
understand this particular finding and
and actually a lot of the other ones
that are kind of on the on the
hyperarousal Spectrum would be if you
think about meditation as a attention
enhancing
product you know like it it gets often
compared with or sort of marketed
alongside Ridin and mapel
and coffee and caffeine and you know all
these stimulants that that help
attention and so if you think about if
you think about meditation as one of
those I mean think
about which is an antipsy drug for
people who don't recognize it yeah if
you think about any of the consequences
and many of us have personal experience
with a lot of these substances taking
too many of them to taking too much just
drink too much coffee what happens you
have a panic attack and you can't sleep
you know like you take amphetamines or
cocaine or you know whatever whatever
the stimulant is you take enough of it
and it's going to be on the fear
spectrum and some of them if you take
enough of that it's going to be on the
psychosis Spectrum especially if you
have sort of tendencies in that
direction so it's not doesn't seem like
a huge leap to think that like here's
another you know attention enhancing
product that with certain people and
certain types of doses it's going to
lead to a hyperarousal syndrome and
that's pretty much exactly what we're
seeing so that is one of the potential
mechanisms so what I might do for folks
who just don't have the personal context
on me that I alluded to earlier is I'll
I'll tell if it's okay with you a bit of
my story which in some ways led to this
conversation and certainly I it sounds
like based on what we were discussing
before recording that that people have
mentioned this to you and it's so it's
been it's been a match made for many
reasons so I want to give folks sort of
a contrast by giving present day and
then the story of what happened to me at
my silent Retreat which was a Vasa
Retreat so if we look at for instance
the last two weeks I have meditated
twice a day 20 minutes a day very
straightforward Transcendental
Meditation and there's lots of wacky
weird stuff if you go deep enough and
weird enough with with TM but if you're
taking it for the off-the-shelf offering
and following the basic guidelines I
find it incredibly therapeutic and I
find also difficult to disambiguate I
haven't had any caffeine whatsoever in
two weeks so the combination of those
two for I suppose a lot of sensible
reasons seems to really help sleep I've
been getting some of the best sleep in
the last 10 years probably in the last
one or two weeks I'm sure the abstinence
from coffee and caffeine no small part
of that and I've seen no Adverse Events
whatsoever and I've done a lot of TM
over the years and other types of
meditation but TM I find to be the
easiest life raft of sorts however if we
flash back and this sort of alludes to
the maybe like the paracelis the dose
makes the poison I approached my
Meditation Retreat and this was at
Spirit Rock which is a beautiful
beautiful facility beautiful campus
really run by excellent people and ended
up being very fortunate that the author
of the book you mentioned a path with
heart that Jack cornfield was at Spirit
Rock he ended up being the person who
effectively triaged and helped address
the situation I found myself in
ultimately but I I approached the silent
retreat with the wrong mindset and the
wrong set of expectations I thought to
myself I've done lots of meditation if
you add up all the time that I've
meditated it's quite a bit I've spent
time by myself and I've also done a BC d
and e really not recognizing
that they are two different for me at
least and for many people two different
species of experience and since I had
heard that it was the last time Jack
would be leading a retreat I'm not sure
if that ended up being the case or not I
decided that I wanted to get absolutely
as much out of it as possible I'd seen
benefits from fasting before I'd seen
benefits
from uh lower doses of psychedelics
before so I thought to myself this is
probably aggressive but why on a combine
all three and that ended up being
incredibly problematic but not
immediately i' done the fasting so I
fasted going into this weeklong
Retreat and then after after a few days
of establishing my Baseline let's call
it three days I started adding
increasing doses daily
of Blended like homogenized dried COC
mushrooms so people might know these
better as magic mushrooms starting at
about 100 milligrams and then slowly
working up
to about I want to say it was 600 or so
milligrams which is is reasonably high
it's far above what one would consider a
micro do micro do let's just call it 50
to 100
milligram and simultaneously I'm having
this first experience of being silent
for effectively the entire day maybe
outside of asking a question or two at a
Dharma talk at night this is brand new
and what ended up happening just to jump
to the punchline
is around I was having difficulty with
the meditation to begin with I was very
physically uncomfortable
my mind began to accelerate in terms of
just rumination the velocity of thought
and velocity sort of implies a direction
it was more like a a pingpong ball
bouncing around or a pinball bouncing
around in a machine at increasing speed
sort of nonlinear exponentially growing
speed and it was very uncomfortable and
then I want to say around day four or
five I had this flooding of M memories
of childhood abuse and it wasn't just
snapshots it was like being stuck in a
fully
immersive VR experience that was as
convincing as this reality whenever I
closed my eyes so whenever I closed my
eyes that's what I saw it was a
reexperiencing of this these traumatic
experiences from Age 2 to 4 and if
people go to tim. blog truma they can
listen to a podcast about this and
certain modalities that have helped me
but nonetheless I did not expect this
and I was utterly incapable of stopping
it I could not stop it and this went
talk about not sleeping anytime I closed
my eyes so I couldn't sleep so now what
do you have you have
compounding lack of sleep and I had
never heard of this before I didn't
think this was a possibility I certainly
thought it was a unique experience
unique to me I should be able to figure
this out but eventually got so desperate
I was like I'm not going to be to
function I mean I I I am able to
navigate my daytoday here right now with
extreme pain but I've I have no
confidence I'll be able to go back to
normal life and make decisions manage my
business interact in all the ways that
are necessary and that's when I set up
meeting with Jack and thankfully he had
the experience he has a lot of
experience also as a clinical
psychologist with Cutters with people
who have been abused with veterans who
have lost limbs and have moral injuries
and PTSD he has a lot of mileage with
many different patients and clients and
meditators so he was able to thank
God provide a safety net and provide me
with recommendations to clinicians and
so on therapists I could meet to try to
address this but if he had not been
there I shudder to think what would have
happened so that's the story and
ultimately was able to to sort of pull
out of it and manage life but not
everyone has access to Jack and the
contrast and I'll I'll shut up in a
second between my day to-day over the
last two weeks all upside and that
experience are just black and white I
mean there's there's really no
comparison interestingly and I'll add
one more thing I recently spent a week
in I ation in the wilderness fasting for
that entire week and it was not nearly
as challenging but I did see some
similar symptoms let's say in terms of
that increased speed of the pinball
bouncing around in my head as did
another person I was with so two for two
without any attempt to meditate which
raises all sorts of questions right so
it's hard for me to parse what caused
what I experienced but I know that it
was terrible and without Jack I would
have been [__] for lack of a better uh
technical
term how common is that kind of
experience I guess and uh certainly feel
free to start wherever you'd like
or pick that apart in any way that makes
sense uh but it was a disaster
unmitigated disaster and I'm very
fortunate I had someone like Jack
because I had actually spoken with one
other a junior teacher at the time and
she was unequipped she she was not
equipped to handle what was happening
but Jack
was yeah so many different
thought thank you for coming to my TED
Talk yeah I mean one is just
wow and like wow on so many ways like
wow that that happened to you and two
that you're talking about it you
know publicly
that's amazing so thank you because I
think it's going to be really help to a
lot of people
MH maybe a second thought is you're
definitely not alone you're definitely
not the only one there were probably
other people on your retreat that this
was happening to and
that in my work at cheetah house I see
someone like that every day I I try to
see at least one person every day I'm
seeing someone later today actually
so this to me is like my bread and
butter I see it all the time like it's
so common but like what are the actual
percentages is that's where we get into
the rabbit hole of research and
frequency research which is which is
actually quite complicated because it's
about like what do you mean by
this right you know and like frequent
among who and so it's you know it
becomes more complicated and I guess one
other
question
is given what I do like that I'm you
know an expert on meditation related
challenges and and neurobiology is there
anything that we can talk about that
would be useful to you to sort of make
sense of you do you have any lingering
questions that haven't been answered yet
so that that's I'll just put that out
there and then the another thing is like
let's create a public service
announcement for people like you because
let me tell you males 18 to 30 who think
that combining every possible powerful
tool all at once yeah to you know Break
On Through To The Other Side is a story
that I see again over and over and over
again doesn't always turn out well
you're saying no it's more like a risk
factor yeah yeah for sure at cheetah
house we have a a program called to my
former self where people come on who did
stuff like that and then they're like
honey let me tell you like what I wish
I'd known when I was like your age and
they tell you know you you tell your
former self advice I would love you to
do that should also be a letter to your
future self so you don't do the same
thing again I do have a couple of
questions and well a few observations
and a couple of questions so looking
back at that experience
separately prior to that experience and
afterwards I had a lot of experience
with f fasting including extended fasts
and a lot of experience with
psychedelics and that was premeditation
Retreat and certainly
post based on my last experience over
the last 3 weeks where I was in
isolation in the wilderness fasting and
so
on I tend to wait in this particular
case the fasting as a an
exacerbating Factor more than the micro
doing of psychedelics which is not to
recommend to anyone that they combine
things on their first Meditation Retreat
look there are lots of meditation
Retreats do it the plain vanilla away
first would be my strong recommendation
it's going to be hard enough don't worry
would be recommendation number one there
are some people and this is going to
lead to my question like you've all know
Harari who wrote sapiens who I've had on
the podcast who does a silent Meditation
Retreat for a month every year as far as
I can tell and handles it Like A
Champion it is like a warm bath for his
mind I found it much harder I'm sure
there are people who find it harder my
question is this what are the not
necessarily exclusionary criteria but
what are some of the characteristics or
profiles that make someone more
vulnerable or likely to have this type
of experience because for instance if
you look at classical psychedelics and
we could spend a lot of time defining
what that means but broadly speaking
let's just say with
the the Usual Suspects that a lot of
people would recognize let's say LSD
psilocybin Etc there are certainly
others iasa could be thrown into this
for n
ndmt that if you have a family history
of
schizophrenia it is likely a bad idea
for you to engage with using these
things simply because not to say that it
will make you schizophrenic in a
lifetime where you would otherwise not
become schizophrenic but it could
expedite the onset of symptoms and there
are many documented cas casis of this so
in a case that you have family history
of schizophrenia maybe you should not
consume these things and I'm wondering
what the intake form right should look
like what does the intake look like for
a Meditation Retreat so that a
facilitator could say you know what I
think maybe you should do 20 minutes a
day or 30 minutes a day but not do 7
Days silent because that would be like
taking iasa for
schizophrenic how would you think about
the the things that make it more likely
so I think this is a very natural place
to start which is sort of you know
screening out people who shouldn't
meditate and now I'm going to unpack why
that's a very difficult thing to do yep
so I conducted a epidemiological study
with bie Davidson and Simon Goldberg
looking at meditation related adverse
effects how often they happen and and
risk factors and so you know
statistically speaking there is an
increased risk factor for a large range
of of variables that would be considered
stressors adversity so trauma history
psych history being some kind of
minority group whether it's racial
minority or sexual orientation minority
something like that is going to be a
chronic stressor and that's going to be
you know heighten the risk for adverse
effects but at the same time and so it's
it's very easy to just sort of well
those people shouldn't meditate you know
it's very easy to to kind of do that
well first of all you know more than 90%
of people have exposure to a Criterion a
stressor so that would be like almost
everyone gets ruled out right except for
the extremely sheltered and privileged
which would be like not what we're
trying to do with you know meditation is
just limited to those
people and then in our the variet of
contemplative experience study we found
that a lot of the risk factors that were
the most obvious ones to consider like
psych and Trauma history they didn't
know what they were doing in incorrect
practice that kind of
thing that none of those actually panned
out to be true and so in in our study
60% of the people who had meditation
related
challenges were themselves meditation
teachers so they were getting
correct practice instructions they were
meditating correctly they had good
supervision they had good knowledge
about what to do and there were a number
of people that did not have psychiatric
or trauma histories and so while those
are risk factors it doesn't mean that if
you don't have them that you're safe
right so the sort of take-home message
from me
is I'm not a big fan of screening people
out I think the the the other side of
this is that there are a lot of people
and then and this might be not as true
for psychedelics as it is for meditation
but meditation is being marketed for
schizophrenia for psychosis for bipolar
disorder for all the things that you
might as a retreat manager want a red
flag so you can't it would be just
strange thing to start saying oh you
can't those people can't have access to
this
technology so and I've gotten letters
from people that say like you know
please don't just rule us out people
with what would be considered serious
mental illness MH please don't just rule
us out because we seem like it would be
a bad idea for us because well let me
pause for one second and just say it
seems to depend on the type of
meditation we're talking talking about
right for meditating 20 minutes in the
morning there might be one intake but
for doing a 7-Day silent Retreat there
might be a different intake right so I
don't know if you're able to speak to
that because those two things I mean had
about as much in common for me as like
playing with a Hot Wheels car on the top
of your kitchen table and like driving
an F1 car around a hairpin turn like
they were about they're like yeah they
both involve cars okay but they right I
guess my point is is that I think that
the action item here is not screening
people out as much as being much more
informed about how to monitor them
closely and how to have more
off-ramps as part of the retreat okay
can we pause for a second yeah so I want
to talk about that I want to give people
just so not everyone is like oh my God
the next time I meditate is my am I
going to have a psychic implosion and
end up in a straight jacket just to put
some numbers to things I want to read
something here and just have you fact
check this so people have some numbers
on prevalence and also just a a
comparative sort of parallel of sorts
that uh we'll spend a little bit of time
on then I want to talk about safety
training monitoring and off-ramps and
things like that so this is from
mindfulness exercises.com.au
definition of adverse effects in hand
will be and her team set out to research
the true prevalence of Life impacting
adverse effects following meditation the
first surprising result was that their
epidemiological sample indicated nearly
half of the US population has meditated
at least once I'm sure that's higher now
of these people 6 to 14% had lasting
negative effects so that's what I wanted
to bring up a number that closely M the
adverse effects of psychotherapy 5 to
133% is that roughly accurate would you
say the frequency research is very
challenging and so I do think that the
epidemiological study is probably the
the most valid research but the somehow
that the data that they're citing is
actually from combining two different
studies okay got it so the
epidemiological study the denominator
was anyone who's ever meditated even
once mhm so that's like kind of the
lowest common denominator so like the
lowest possible chance and within that
study we found that that people who had
tried meditation even once half of them
would have at least
one negative effect and it could be
extremely brief you know like no big
deal more concerning is that 10% so one
in 10 people who had tried meditation
even once would have a meditation
related adverse effect that was
associated with impairment and
functioning and so we can go down the
rabbit hole of definitions if you want
but I think that for me
like having a a negative experience
during meditation which we call negative
veilance I don't consider that an
adverse effect I think that if you're if
you don't have some kind of negative
experience in your meditation at some
point you're probably sleeping because
it's it's not a warm bath for the mind
it can be challenging so I'm not worried
about that part but I'm more worried
about if it has a negative impact on
your life and functioning off the
cushion than I'm like okay that's when
we not start need to start talking about
whether there's maybe
Alternatives and so one and 10 is really
the number that is jumping out of that
paper the other paper which was a
clinical trial that I did much smaller
trial very selected sample of people who
have kind of clinical to subclinical
anxiety and depression that came up with
the 5 to
15% they correlate with each other but
yeah so what are some things that we can
do to risk mitigate in terms of and you
can you can pick whichever makes sense
to start with but training for
instructors or monitoring I'm actually
pretty interested in the monitoring I'm
interested in all of it and then
off-ramps what to do if somebody does
have a break I suppose like I did I I
wouldn't necessarily describe it as a
psychotic break but I felt out of
control right I felt like I was not able
to I was I would not be able to function
normally had I returned to normal life
without some intervention what can we do
to make things safer I suppose I think
it helps to start
with we created a taxonomy of 59
categories of meditation related
challenges and it wasn't until many
years later that I went through the
sematic experiencing trauma training
that I started to actually see a lot of
those 59 categories in terms of trauma
symptoms and in terms of symptoms of the
way that the body tends to react to
extreme
stress and that these are these are not
necessarily so Altered States but things
that that might be somewhat recognizable
to people so one of the ways that I
think is the most e efficient way
because we can train meditation teachers
and
like I have you know online courses
where you're like they have quizzes on
the 59 categories and you you know
there's all this content that they need
to learn but I actually think that the
best way to do it is to train each
individual person it to be like Tim how
do you know when you're getting outside
of your window of Tolerance when you're
like how do you know when you're feeling
quote unquote out of control like what
is your indicator for that mhm you can
just answer that sure it's when I seem
incapable or maybe when I am incapable
of stopping very highspeed negative
rumination I suppose it would be like
perseverating on either a a real event
like a memory or a perceived threat like
a hypothetical worst case scenario and I
just Loop and loop and loop and loop and
I'm furthermore aware of the looping
right like there's part of me as the
Observer that's like holy [__] I can't
believe I seem incapable of stopping
this I know it's not productive I know
it's not helping me and yet it just goes
and goes and goes that would be my
canary in the coal mine or maybe a flock
of canaries in the coal mine is there
anything that is an earlier indicator
than that before you get
there I would say it's more I've
realized realized which factors can
contribute to
that it's something for me that comes on
so this may be a dissatisfying answer
but it's something that can come on
really
suddenly but I would say that over
caffeination right lack of
sleep fasting there are a handful of
things that seem
more likely to precipitate this type of
experience than other things and doesn't
happen all the time but I would
say probably if I were to try to back
into what I described I'm sure that it
starts
with and I'm sure it started I have to
imagine at my vapas retreat with having
bouts of this come up and then trying to
suppress it I'm sure that's it took some
form like that I I I would have to
imagine it was something like that and
just to quid proquo mean I have lots of
them but I think my mouth gets dry is
like an indication of sympathetic
activation yeah interesting yeah I get
really hot mhm and when I'm like really
about to like a strong stressor for me
is when the my visual field starts to
get wonky and that's when the sort of
dissociation sets in things get a little
spacey so if this was a meditation class
I would have everyone go around and talk
about their own personal indicators mhm
because no matter how much research we
do those indicators are there there's
going to be a lot of overlap but there's
also going to be some individual
differences and really what matters is
that the person knows what their their
indicators are they're like okay my
system is stressed like it needs you
know don't keep doing what you're doing
that's making this happen let's dial it
back mhm and unfortunately the response
is often like well just keep going just
keep meditating keep doing whatever
you're doing like you're going to you
know at some point there's going to be a
breakthrough but instead it's just gets
worse mhm that is more of the angle that
I'm taking is like teaching everybody
what their indicator lights are just
like you don't get in a car and drive
until you know like okay the the gas the
gas meter here like this is the tire
pressure like you know you have these
indicator lights and we have them we
have indicator lights and we all need to
be sort of trained on what they are
individually and that will keep you a
lot safer when you know what your
indicator lights are I think one of the
things that undermines that is this sort
of Fascination and romanticization of
Altered States and you can think of
Altered
States as a deviation from Baseline a
deviation from homeostasis which is in
trauma in trauma speak that is
disregulation you know an altered state
is not necessarily a good idea for
someone who is trying to stay stable and
so just having people be able to track
that and like okay like that thing my
indicator light is
on what typically helps that and go do
that I need to go lift some weights I
need to go Dial Bat and you skip the
coffee this afternoon or like maybe eat
something
by the way the the fasting thing is
really really
interesting we had a lot of information
in the varieties project about diet but
we really hadn't done anything with it
and actually one of my students this
year has just started to delve into the
diet data and is finding that it's
really making a difference that a lot of
people have reported that when you go on
meditation Retreats because they they
tend to be vegetarian and they tend to
feed you very light food sometimes not
even there's sometimes there's no
dinner and so you know it's not fasting
so much but it's definitely like you're
you're going off of your like my
personal high fat high protein diet like
I I get very unregulated and floaty and
and sort of ungrounded when I go on
Retreats and I really want to have like
heavy food and so a lot of people found
that to be a
factor and found that actually eating
really high fat protein meat is a remedy
for problems and this is also you know
recommended within Tibetan medicine and
like and old you know Buddhist text
textual reports will also report eating
meat and heavy heavy Foods oils can also
be something that can help sort of bring
people down and more grounded and when
we interviewed the teachers as teachers
which was a second part of the study
there was really not a lot of consensus
about like what was a problem what
wasn't a problem what was a risk factor
what wasn't but there were two things
and one was when the person stops
sleeping and when the person stops
eating that like that's when you
intervene so those were the two things
that all teachers mentioned as being
something that they worry about let me
hop in for a second just to mention
something that I found in the process
of doing homework for this is was
actually in a Harper's
piece about you and your team and it
discussed something that I've also seen
which does not really get discussed so
I'm bringing it up very
deliberately post
certain potent psychedelic experiences
so this is something that now I've seen
described here as a adverse effect of
meditation possibly for some folks and
also I've seen this post psychedelic and
this is I'll just I'll just read quote
practicing letting go of Concepts one
meditator told Britain was sabotaging my
mind's ability to lay down new memories
and reinforce old memories of simple
things like what words mean and colors
mean what I'm going to underline is
what's coming next meditators also
reported diminished emotions both
negative and positive quote I had two
young
children um another meditator said I
couldn't feel anything about them I went
through all the routines you know the
bedtime routine getting them ready and
King them and all that stuff but there
was no emotional connection it was like
I was dead end quote so
this anhedonia let's call it which
interestingly can also be for some
people addressed with psychedelics but
what's less talked about is that they
can be
initiated in some people by psychedelics
where they come out and they're sort of
numb to the world right and people think
of the amigdala is this fear Center but
it's not exactly a fear Center so maybe
you could just speak to this particular
manifestation of issue because I've seen
it in both camps there's kind of two
different ways that this can happen with
meditation and and
psychedelics with
meditation if you look at
the Neuroscience of meditation and
there's lots of different kinds but like
we'll just say like concentration
practice you tend to
see a regulation of the lyic system the
amydala and you know activation of the
prefrontal cortex so attention system
goes
up downregulates the lmic system and
again this is this can be great good
things you know like you regulate all
your all your anxiety and depression but
if you keep
going then you're going to see a
downregulation of not just negative
emotions but also positive ones people
forget that like the amydala is you know
a sing detector for all sorts of things
positive and
negative and you're going to see if you
continue to downregulate your lyic
system with
meditation and you take it far enough
then you you will see you know a
decrease in the intensity of of all
emotions and that can lead you know
otherwise known as anadon but depends on
you know according to obis suery that
could also be something that's that's
could be equinity so depends on what you
want tomato
tomato obviously the person who didn't
feel anything for her children that was
not her goal but I actually that
particular quote that you're reading I
read that quote in a conference and a
Buddhist scholar like jumped up at the
end and said you know cutting
attachments with affection with your
families is exactly what you're supposed
to be doing and so I was like okay well
we need to talk about what you're goals
are so yeah thou doth protest too much
so with with meditation like there is
overlap so what's interesting about that
model prefinal cortex control over the
lyic system is that that's also the
Neuroscience of
dissociation so there are certain forms
of meditation that
mimic the exact neurobiology of
dissociation that's one way to end up in
this place I call that the low road
because you're just basically just
taking everything down getting calmer
and calmer and
calmer the high road is the is the one
we were talking about earlier where
you're training your attention and
everything's up regulating and you're
getting more and more and more like your
thoughts are racing and you're having
flooding of traumatic experiences and
everything's getting heightened and at
some point your system's like whoa this
is too much and you have this beautiful
adaptive
natural breaker
switch called dissociation that will
basically shut down the lyic system
again and you'll basically end up in
that first state that I just talked
about where you have like a strong
activation of the prefrontal cortex and
a downregulation of the lyic
system and so it's two different roads
to the same place and so what's
interesting in sort of the overlap with
psychedelics is that too much kind of
response that that can lead to
dissociation it doesn't always have to
be
negative people can have like a euphoric
unitive experience where they like they
merge with the universe or they have
just something just ecstatic kind of
experience but their organism is like
that was that was too intense that was
too much for me I'm turning I'm turning
on the breaker and they wake up in the
morning and they're like they feel dead
and they spend like years trying to
recreate that awesome
experience
but they're you know they're not really
listening to their organism's messages
which is saying like that was too
intense are you listening there is a
very interesting overlap at cheetah
house when people come for help we see
the combination of of psychedelics and
meditation very often a lot of times in
this scenario where they go on a
Meditation Retreat have an ecstatic
experience or just a very intense
experience wake up feeling dead and
anatonic and they think I gota I got to
sort of like shock the system back
into into action and they go take a
psychedelic and that just makes things
worse because the system's like I'm been
trying to tell you that this is too much
and now you're just really pushing the
envelope and the and we also see the
opposite people who have the the initial
experience on psychedelics and then they
decide well I'm very disre ated and they
get told you know by by various
authorities you should go on a
Meditation Retreat or you should
meditate either way at least the people
who show up at cheetah house the
combination was not the answer for them
let me hop in for a second just
to ask a few followup questions
on Retreats
specifically are there any intensive
Retreats that
you recommend or extended
Retreats and I suppose the broader
question is how how can one know where
to
practice and vet properly right if
someone wants to do a Meditation Retreat
and the reason I ask is for instance
with psychedelics which are still
largely underground at this point even
though at some point hopefully there
will be an entire framework for
administering them reasonably safely to
people who fit certain
criteria if someone finds a facilitator
says I've never had no one under my care
has ever had a bad trip that is a huge
red flag because it means they're either
diluting themselves they're lying or
they're really inexperienced right those
are kind of the only options on the
table because you're you're effectively
using nuclear
power to change the you plasticity of
the Mind
of course there are going to be Adverse
Events of course there are going to be
outliers and so you want someone who has
actually handled those cases right if
you go to to push my F1 analogy if you
go to a racetrack let's just say and
you're going to a track day and the
track owner says we've never had any
accident of any type on our track that's
a bad thing because someone's going to
have an accident you want to make sure
they have protocols in place they have
experience they have the presence of
mind to handle it calmly etc etc so I
could see that applying also to
vetting meditation Retreats but putting
myself in the position of someone
listening to this I might say holy [__]
of the people who have tried meditation
once X percentage have these persistent
problems like this seems really really
dangerous maybe I just shouldn't
meditate so for those people to maybe
offset that a little bit are there
Retreats that you ever recommend and how
can someone vet if they're considered
doing a
retreat I mean I think that a lot of it
has to do with matching the goals to the
person so I don't want to necessarily
rule out or recommend any particular
Retreat across the board yeah I think
that there are certain Retreats that are
pretty repeat offenders MH and those are
ones that have like high dose like 15
hours of meditation a day no movement
practice mhm often you see an
alternation between walking right and
sitting and sometimes there's even yoga
added so you know more intense
practices with no movement and also not
necessarily tailored feedback from
teachers MH so I would be very careful
before going on one of those and I think
just General like there are so many
different options for Retreats these
days you can do like an afternoon
Retreat where it's only a couple hours
like start there tight trate up and you
can do this at home you don't even have
to necessarily spend the money you can
just download an app and do that for a
day and see how you do you know like
tight trate up and and just do it like
one at a day at a time if you're worried
about like you know rather than signing
up for a 10day Retreat something I have
not mentioned before is that I've done
shorter meditation Retreats like two or
three days with no issues whatsoever
yeah so I just want to point that out
the other fine detail that I want to
mention because I think Spirit Rock runs
a very good ship and I think they're
very well formatted and they do have
safeguards in place that they
explicitly advise against fasting and I
violated that rule I overrode that right
and also added the psychedelics which
certainly I had not mentioned to anyone
until I had already sort of
capsized yeah so I think those are
definitely things I mean that this this
never used to be an issue but I know
that that people are doing that that
that people are
bringing psychedelics on Retreats and I
think a lot of the
Retreats they have to manage a lot of
people yeah people are already having
like challenging
experiences the regular kind of
challenging
experiences with meditation and so to
have to to manage people who are also
taking psychedelics is that's a lot it's
not really fair to a Meditation Retreat
so I think it's going to be invisible to
them for the most part yeah I'm sure
right it's not going to be reported just
like people lie on their medical intakes
about the psychiatric medications
they're taking if they are wedded to
taking psychedelics with a facilitator
this happens all the time people sort of
misrepresent their health
status because they're so vested in this
last Hail Mary Obi-Wan Kenobi or final
hope solution Panacea that they see in
psychedelics and I have to imagine that
also happens with meditation Retreats
I'd love for you to say a bit more about
repeat offenders are there any
other
characteristics or format issues that
you see producing more problems than
others outside of what you already
mentioned so in terms of the retreat or
meditation type or in terms of personal
risk factors The Retreat or meditation
type that seem to produce a higher
volume of people with these
issues I would say Retreats that recruit
or are attracting a certain type of
meditator which by the way
like you fit the bill like pretty
exactly when I heard this story I was
like wow like that's pretty emblematic
of like textbook yeah young male pretty
educated combining all sorts of of tools
you know fairly aggressive we used to
joke that one of the risk factors was
zealotry the kind of zealotry
Zeal so something like that and so
people there's a certain kind of almost
like mill
milary this is going to be a really
really hard Retreat like those types of
Retreats are a little bit more highrisk
and I think there's also the combination
of the person and the teacher/ format
mhm one of the things that we found that
was really shocking in the varieties of
contemplative experience study is that
on one hand we expected to see people
who ran into problems as people who had
lots of problems in their lives but when
we actually like looked at the data like
75% had graduate degrees MD phds
JDS you know these were like CEOs of
major companies these are like super
high achieving people and we were like
this is so interesting how do we make
sense of that and we're like oh right
being a high achiever is a risk factor I
was just about to say like the drug
addiction in the medical profession is
off the charts like suicides off the
charts so right it's because like these
are the kinds of people that you're like
okay he you're going to sit and follow
your breath you know and they're like
okay like they're the ones that show up
early for the meditation and they're the
last ones to leave are the ones that are
like they follow instructions exactly
they would never modify the instructions
for their own benefit that would not
even occur to them unless they make it
more intense and this is kind of where
trauma comes in if you've been trained
to scan what are the expectations here
what are the sort of unspoken social
rules that I need to Ace in order to not
be punished if that's like kind of youro
running in the background then we have
all these people like following
instructions exactly not modifying them
basically listening to an external
Authority rather than their own internal
Compass that's the recipe for disaster
and so if you can interface with you
know really any type of meditation
spiritual system with your having
maintaining your inner
Compass that's going to be a recipe for
a much better outcome but not not
everybody can do that and not all
systems are tolerant of that and so I
would also encourage and we've had lots
of trainings with meditation centers
trying to be able to be able to be more
flexible and so if somebody knows like I
need to be able to leave the meditation
you know in the middle so that I'm not
like continuing to meditate and the
meditation manager Meditation Retreat
manager is like no that won't be allowed
you have to say if you come you have to
stay for the whole thing that's not
really allowing flexibility so are there
ways that people can titrate the amount
of practice that they're getting within
a retreat is there a way to like hey on
on Wednesday we'll have Burger night for
people who need to like increase the
like fat intake you know that is
actually happening now yeah the
vegetarian diet piece is super
interesting I mean I I don't know if the
sort of Acuity is is sufficient as a
factor but it it makes me think also
with for instance some of these
conditions that are let's just say
contraindicated for most psychedelic use
schizophrenia borderline personality
disorder understanding these are all
kind of like word salad things taken
from the DSM which is kind of a big
question mark for a lot of reasons but
some of these more for lack of better
terms of chaotic conditions are
contraindicated respond really well to
something called metabolic Psychiatry
with Chris Palmer has spoken about this
out of Harvard using high fat
effectively ketogenic diet but like high
fat moderate protein some of these
people respond incredibly well so if you
look though at the food served at these
meditation Retreats uniformly
effectively the exact polar opposite
right which is kind of
interesting do you meditate do you
meditate now or is that not a practice
for you ooh that's a long long story all
right let's do it depends on what you
mean by meditate okay so meditation when
I first undertook it you know with
Jack's sort of meditation came from a
specific tradition and it had a whole
bunch of implicit goals and values that
weren't really clear to me cuz I was
just like suffering and so I thought I'm
just going to do this so I won't feel
like so much panic and anxiety and Etc
I've done tens of thousands of hours of
meditation I've been the expert
meditator in many brain Imaging studies
like I've done I've done my
time as a Buddhist
meditator but I I've started to
understand that there's a whole set of
implicit values that like I didn't
necessarily choose what would be an
example if you don't mind well so an
example is the that the ideal affect or
the the goal emotion state is more on
the calm end of
things right and as like a a direct
descendant of General George S Patton
like it's not really in my blood to be
calm
so more of a border collie less of a
great day yeah yeah anyway there's lots
of people who their ideal state is not
Calm And so there's lot of implicit
values and I think that this is just
something as meditation is moving into
the west and kind of mixing with a lot
of different cultures and subcultures
and goals and values like can these
contemplative practices be used for many
different types of goals rather than
ones that you know were preset as part
of a religious practice and I think that
is
happening but for myself in particular I
have you know specific practices that I
do that I have permission now from
myself to modify practice to not just
follow the rules the way that I did
before and end up somewhere that I
didn't want to go but rather to modify
things and and make sure that I'm going
where I want to go but that also
requires me to like actually sit down
with myself and be like where do you
want to go yeah which is another thing
that I recommend for people Amy man has
a song write down what you need before
you sign away the deed you know like
make sure you know like what you want
because you're going to get on a highway
and it's going to be kind of fast
tracking you to somewhere making sure
that you are actually going where you
want to go I want to know what practices
that you follow not to imply that anyone
should just copy paste right you got to
know your own needs but I am curious
like where you've landed personally so
you tell me where would you like to
start start okay so I want to go to the
varieties of contemplative experience
this was the study that took us 10 years
and we came up with 59 categories of
meditation
related challenges and adverse effects
and we we categorize them into seven
different domains cognitive perceptual
affective which is emotional somatic
cognitive which is motivational sense of
self and social so I'm not going to go
through all 59 people can look them up
they're on the cheetah House website
under symptoms but just to give you like
a sort of basic overview of what is in
each
category so cognitive types of
experiences are increase in thought
frequency which you talked about trouble
with executive functioning so making
decisions paying
attention the loss of conceptual meaning
structures which you also
mentioned probably the most famous
example is the woman who on the way back
from Retreat stopped at a red light saw
the the red color but didn't register
what it meant that it meant stop oh boy
you can see how that would be yeah
problematic sometimes you need your
Concepts you need your Concepts so
that's the cognitive domain perceptual
you see perceptual hypers sensitivity
you can also see
hallucinations Visions changes in
perception also changes in you know D
realization so feeling like you're in a
dream or things feel flat or cartoon
like emotions can go in either direction
which we've already kind of touched on
so you know increases in in fear and
panic and reexperiencing of trauma but
also affect of blunting so loss of
emotions
altogether you can also see in the
sematic domain we can see else's energy
like sematic experiences we have an
entire paper on that wait say that again
what does that stand for El's energy
like sematic experiences so so
experiences of of sort of electricity or
voltage or going through the body mhm we
talked about insomnia already and lots
of different kinds of pain syndromes
headaches different kinds of pains in
terms of cognitive or
motivational
again
insane just Enlightenment or bust kind
of changes in motivation like you know
sorry honey like I'm gone I'm going to
go shave my head and become a monk like
we see that all the time and then the
opposite like complete loss of
motivation why would I do anything no
goals
whatsoever the sense of self domain is
my personal favorite I teach an entire
class on it called me myself and I but
there's lots of changes in senses of
self and that can range from The
Narrative self the story of me your
identity self all the way down to your
sense of ownership over your own body
over Body Sensations
emotions thoughts and then also down to
your sense of self Other Self World
boundaries can
dissolve which has you we have a whole
paper on that as well and obviously
there's a lot of overlap with
psychedelics with that particular
category so we can unpack that if you
want and then within the social domain
not
surprisingly if you're having these
experiences it can be related to all
kinds of social consequences people
don't like hearing about this they have
all sorts of reactions wait till you get
your responses to this episode yeah I
want to talk about the doy Lama too
before we people don't like to hear
about this so a lot of people get
shunned by their communities sometimes
they get you know their teachers get
irritated with them and then there's
also trying to go to work and trying to
explain why you can't function so
there's all sorts of social dynamics
that go with that so that was kind of
the the quick and dirty overview of the
59 categories I will say that within
that particular study the varieties of
contemplative experience
study we looked at duration of symptoms
and duration of impairment and duration
of impairment the average was 1 to three
years so it was quite a bit of time and
the IT ranged from a few days to more
than a decade
so this can be and I think you know your
experience you can kind of understand
why it could be quite a long time before
you recover if you don't happen upon
Jack horfield for a while yeah I won the
lottery on that latter part of things
and the the duration you're describing I
just want to draw a couple of parallels
me already alluded to this but you could
take almost everything you just
mentioned if not everything and map it
to Adverse Events related to psychedelic
experiences right pretty much everything
I think everything that you mentioned
and in terms of duration there's
something that doesn't get talked about
very much also because it
is viewed as perhaps risking the cause
and the momentum of the Psychedelic
Renaissance but there's something it's a
bit of a mouthful I wish it had a better
name but hppd hallucinogen persisting
perception disorder Y and I know people
who have experienced this where they are
effectively hallucinating on some level
for years y uh I have a family member
who experienced this uh by marriage I
have
a very close friend who experienced this
for the second half of his undergrad and
for several years afterwards and people
can find more on this online but I
suppose we could move into scaffolding
but I'd like to ask you are there any
particular distinctions clear
differences between meditation related
Adverse Events and psychedelic related
Adverse
Events well we don't really know yeah
that was actually a study that we're in
the middle of collecting data on
so I think that I'm glad that you
mentioned that there's a lot of overlaps
because I'm also seeing them and a lot
of people that have had both
experiences are mentioning that there is
a lot of overlap so the study that we're
conducting is basically looking at how
much they overlap and whether there are
systematic differences if I had to guess
I would say that the perceptual changes
the hppd like
changes would be more common in the
Psychedelic world I do think there's
something neurological going on there
that might be not happening in all forms
of meditation but we definitely see like
visual
snow and there can be some perceptual
changes that are enduring visual changes
that are enduring but if you look at the
hppd literature it's actually a lot more
than just visual changes there's a whole
lot of different things going on so yeah
I think that's a really interesting
question how they compare but also with
whether somebody's a dual
and whether it's changing a lot of
people are doal users yeah it's very
hard to
disambiguate the resource I want to
recommend and I can't vouch for it
personally because fortunately I I do
not have hppd but the more people use
these compounds meaning psychedelics of
various types the more this is going to
become prevalent and really need proper
addressing there is a website it's
perception. foundation and that's the
perception restoration Foundation they
have resources they have frequently
asked questions about hppd they have a
documentary trailer they also have a
specialist directory I cannot vouch for
the capabilities of any of the
Specialists but a lot of people who
experien this feel the way I
did in the midst of my silent Retreat
which is I am broken I don't know how to
fix this everyone else seems fine I
don't even know what to call this and
there's a real sense
of futility or hopelessness that can
come with that
so suffice to say the perception
restoration Foundation may be a place to
start I can't vouch for it but
perception. foundation for folks who may
want to look that up what is
scaffolding for people who come to
cheetah house and let me just back up a
little bit about the cheetah house sort
of origin story I mean the actual
cheetah house started as a halfway house
for brown students who wanted to become
monastics because of our contemplative
studies program so kids will get
meditation training in school in as part
of college they get so inspired by it
that they want to go to India and ordain
as monks and going there and coming back
and living in dorms as a celibate you
know non intoxicant taking college
students doesn't really work so they
lived at cheetah house that was the
original function of cheetah house was
to support sort of semi monastic Brown
students and is it true cheetah is a
play on words the name cheetah is a play
on words it's a play on the Sanskrit
term chitta which means Loosely
mind all right when we started doing the
varieties of contemplative experience
study we were interviewing a number of
people who are having meditation related
challenges and some of them had just
gotten out of the hospital and you know
like I'm 27 and I'm living with my
parents like can I live with you you
know and and so I live at Judah house so
this is like you know my house it's a
big Victorian house with lots of floors
and so there was an entire floor where
meditators could live and kind of
recover from whatever was happening so
that was the beginning of cheetah house
it is now entirely
online and it is helping people recover
from meditation related challenges and
number of them they are not able to
meditate at all they're not able to
engage in anything that looks like
meditation like the trauma is you know
all the trauma cues and associations are
around everything meditation so sitting
with your eyes closed sitting on a floor
with your legs
crossed using a soft voice and guidance
all of that triggers the response
trigger City basically half of the like
mental health world just becomes
inaccessible to these people because you
know they go to a therapist and the
therapist is like oh you need to do
mindfulness and they're like no not
mindfulness please anything but
mindfulness so we have to figure out a
way to help people build their own
practice and I think the other piece
that I wanted
to unpack with you mhm after I heard
your podcast was the term ideological
power MH and so ideological power is the
power to control meaning language and
which concepts are available and how
they're used the power to interpret your
own or others experiences Behavior or
feelings and the power to to silence or
undermine the important thing here is
that trauma is associated with
powerlessness and a lack of of options
and a lack of agency
and so for people who have been
traumatized by meditation or meditation
systems any kind of system is
also a form
of ideological power over them so any
even even like CBT is a system any kind
of therapy or model is a system and so
that also becomes something that they're
not able to work with because if feels
controlling it feels like it's some kind
of value system or model that's being
imposed on them so oh man how do you
like how do you work with that and so we
have to start with so this is called
person- centered approach so if you're
my pretend client I would ask you before
you started
meditating or just outside of your
meditation life what is something that
is a resource for you just for General
well-being are we talking about
psychologic wellbeing as a resource what
I typically do is actually ask you to
look around where you are right now and
pick something like a tangible object
that's in your immediate vicinity that's
something that's meaningful to you but
unrelated to meditation right I was
going to say intense exercise I mean
like I've told every girlfriend I've
ever had you know when I when I think
when if you see me trying to sit down
and think my way through a problem for
more than like a half hour just tell me
to go lift some heavy stuff for hour
it's just like tell me to get out of the
house and go exercise and chances are
it'll resolve itself but if I'm looking
for something
meaningful that is near me right
now there's there's quite a bit here
around me at the moment I could say
there's a artist's sketchbook for
working with mostly graphite and Inc
where I do some drawing there is a copy
of the profit by khil Jabron which I
read when I hop in the sauna just read a
couple Pages frequently and then put it
down I could keep going but those are
two so as you're scanning the
environment you'll notice that when I
ask you notice something that's
meaningful right so there's a salience
kind of like glomming on to different
objects skipping over certain areas but
glomming on to certain objects but it's
not that the sance has a different
flavor for each one right so if you were
going to think about I'm going to take
my nervous system in that direction
I'm going to take it in that direction
you could actually start to chart where
you could go different options just by
looking at these different objects like
they're kind of telling you like oh this
will be activating this will be
energizing this will be calming this
will be strength inducing mhm pick a
direction where would you want your
nervous system to go and then pick an
object that goes with that I'll choose
the Sketchbook yeah because that's where
I am totally immersed in some something
present tense I can get lost in artwork
I don't think about whatever mistake I
made in the conversation yesterday I
don't think about whatever [__] I
have to handle tomorrow I find that
very nourishing in a calming way so I'll
choose that and so as I'm watching you I
can see your eyes are kind of going
somewhere that's not anywhere in
particular which means you have probably
some images that are in your mind oh
maybe I'm also looking at the Sketchbook
that's directly past the laptop okay so
maybe more generally but we can work
with that yeah so maybe more generally
when you look at the Sketchbook and
you're talking about it and you're
thinking about what it can do for you
what are you noticing that goes with
that I would say my sympathetic nervous
system seems to
downregulate breathing seems to slow a
little
bit if I'm being totally honest I have
like a small amount of anxiety cuz I was
really consistent with my art for a
while and I've lapsed for the last two
months and I feel badly about it some
level of guilt but that's not what I'm
going for yeah so let me just pause
there so some kind of drop in your
sympathetic nervous system so how is
that manifesting you said you said your
breathing starting to calm down what
else is going with that what are other
ways that you're noticing some muscular
relaxation mhm any particular area Les
tension yeah back
back neck those would be most obvious I
would say less fidgety right less
bouncing of the foot mhm and so as
you're looking at this object this
Sketchbook and talking about it you're
noticing that you're having sympathetic
activation is decreasing it's changing
your breathing there's something
happening in your back that's
easing mhm and as I'm feeding this back
to you what do you noticing that goes
with that it reinforces it it's like a
not exactly positive reinforcement it
sounds like positive reinforcement for
the relaxation so I'm able to settle
into it I suppose this is kind of like
the beginning of
scaffolding this is what it's like
because if I try to say like okay you're
going to focus on your breathing or I'm
going to give you an object to focus on
50% of people who are given the
breath as an object of meditation find
that it is not the optimal it's not a
safe object and it can actually induce
anxiety so if I if I have you pick the
object I couldn't have picked that in a
million years if I got to wander around
your house and be like which one which
thing should I pick I wouldn't have been
able to pick something you know
immediately you have so much going on
and as a meditator you're able to feel
into your environment right and there's
like oh wow these have different flavors
of how they're actually impacting me and
so I would spend an hour with you
unpacking one particular
object and I would be watching how your
hands are moving and you might be like
oh and there's a story that goes with
the Sketchbook you might end up on who
gave you the Sketchbook and like it's
really about that we kind of like go
down this Rabbit Hole together and I'm
tracking your physiology with mine and
if you're very very disregulated and and
dissociated and you're one of those
people who can't feel anything
anymore I can I can notice very small
changes in your physiology and be like
hey remember that one thing that you
just said cuz I saw your eyes brighten
up a little MH I'll be able to sort of
amplify specifically amplify certain
things but I'm following your lead and
so as somebody who's been very
traumatized about power dynamics and
following any kind of instructions feels
like
oppression you know and feeling trapped
in sort of some system if I'm following
you and just reflecting back to you what
I'm seeing that can be a little bit more
palatable to people who so that's kind
of what scaffolding is MH cool and
that's what we offer to to meditators
who have basically developed a trauma
response to meditation itself which can
really rule out a lot of things yeah
that's an elegant workaround SL approach
and I I would say that I'm very I feel
very fortunate
that I don't personally despite the
childhood experience with the abuse have
that aversion to systems or coaches or
teachers I think in part because I'm
such a problem
student in the sense that I I just will
constantly stop things and question
things and I don't feel like I need to
take anything that is just off the rack
so to
speak so I feel very fortunate about
that let me return since I made a
promise to my listeners and to myself
that I would to your
personal practices what is your
self-care look like in that department
what are those practices wherever you
landed so I've been doing this
resourcing for a long time and this
scaffolding MH and where it landed me so
I started to realize that I in some ways
not super surprising but I have a very
strong reaction to living things like
animals and plants and
so I started to realize like how
powerfully impacted
my gardening I started getting really
obsessed with like rare plants and
growing them in a grow light what kind
of rare plants just you to name one I'm
so curious oh just like weird like
tomatoes things that like you can't buy
in the in the grocery store yeah yeah in
the grocery store just things that you
can't find otherwise but basically where
I ended up was my husband and I bought
90 acres in an undisclosed Mountain area
in
Vermont and we built an off-grid cabin
there and it is so awesome
that I think I'm going to move to
Vermont nice OHS I just did it on like
the Tim Ferris podcast
but yeah like this exercise that we just
did if that becomes the practice
replacing the hours a day that I did
with vasana with a practice like that
actually
amplifying
my positive engagement with the world
and what's in it that that grew into
something so beautiful and magnificent
as
this
place mhm
in the mountains and so it's not just a
technique that you do you know at your
house to in order to perform better it's
just completely taken over my life so
that's where I ended up so it sounds
almost epicurian in a way right like
tending the garden engaging with nature
sure not to add label to it do you find
that you derive the benefits you hope to
derive from meditation through these new
this new engagement that you're
referring to if you wanted to paint a
picture of what my daily practice looks
like imagine I'm wearing actually my
plaid shirt like sort of in
commemoration of my Vermont self but
imagine me putting on some carart
overalls and like getting a weed whacker
or chainsaw and going out and like doing
Trail work yeah and even for like like
the basic idea of coming back and having
to do you know writing a paper or
running statistics or
something meditation never really
improved my cognition MH I always found
that I I was sort of at one of those
sleepy meditators I would just get
really really really calm and kind of
like my brain just kind of got dull but
if I go out there and just use power
tools outside in the cold then I'm like
my blood's moving my brain's working
it's that's doing more of what I was
hoping meditation would do and I'm also
just like ecstatically happy which
meditation never did that for me so
there's that humans are built for
movement you got to move like the the
meditation is great but it's for me very
valuable so I will say
that small dose high
frequency High meaning twice a day is
very
strengthening to my life and my
experiences and I spend four to five
times minimum as much time moving every
day right like the movement the movement
is a critical piece of things where can
people find more information with
respect to a class or
training related to The Meditation
related adverse effects preventing them
mitigating them recovering from them
whether it's as a individual or a a
facilitator triner the public facing
sort of service Branch info branch of my
lab is at cheetah house so that's
cheetah like theanimal house likeah
house.org
and there's tons of information on the
website lots of videos and links to
different kinds of symptom specific
resources but if you're interested in
training specifically on the cheetah
House website there's a tab on called
online courses if you're a meditation
teacher or a clinician you can actually
take the courses and there's a quiz and
it will give you you know you can make
sure that you know the content so
there's more information there you can
also sign up for the cheetah house
newsletter and that will that will alert
you to any of the kind of public
lectures that we have we have one a
month and actually we have one today
that's on C which is spiritual
existential religious and
Theological issues in psychedelic
assisted therapies by Roman blitzky so
that's a good one to see today he just
published an article in jamama about
that topic and he'll be unpacking it for
people so we do meditation related
challenges meditation related issues but
also psychedelics are becoming much more
of a topic it's sort of
unavoidable that those the meditation
and psychedelics are
combining yeah absolutely and you know I
want to zoom out for just a quick second
and say
that well actually let me volunteer
something I don't think I've said
publicly which
is we've been talking
about aside among other things these
Adverse Events adverse effects that can
be associated with Med ation different
types different volumes and
psychedelics however I don't want to
lose what I mentioned earlier I may have
gotten the the boundaries the upper and
lower bounds wrong on the numbers but
Adverse Events and
Psychotherapy after my experience of
Spirit Rock I went to one of the most
famous psychotherapists who works with
trauma in the world and if I mentioned
his book everyone would recogn recognize
it who's in in the trade per se and this
guy was one of the most
narcissistic unbelievably unempathetic
people I'd ever met in my life and he
did a tremendous amount of damage I met
with him twice for two individual
sessions and his ego was so out of
control and his sort of recommendations
so intense and so flippant that it did a
tremendous amount of damage and that
took this was related to the childhood
sexual abuse and it took a long time to
undo the damage inflicted by a famous
psychotherapist and I I guess I wanted
to bring this up to say that when you
engage with these mind
altering
modalities WEA or Consciousness altering
modalities assume that you're dealing
with power tools and you need people who
will admit that yes you can cut fingers
off if you use power tools incorrectly
and furthermore
who have lots of
time not just working with clients but
handling Adverse Events
and handling them is not just an issue
of capability it's also an issue of
empathy and will right so Danny Meyer
who's famous for Shake Shack and
hospitality and many different
restaurants grammar SE Tavern and others
has this sort of Matrix on the wall for
employees and it's the will can Matrix
right so just because someone is a
skilled psychotherapist does not mean
they are going to be willing to provide
after care or safety net if you have an
unraveling right so it's it's to me
really important that you sort of assess
practitioners in advance to ensure that
they have in fact handled these cases
and feel very capable and have
demonstrated competency in handling
these things calmly so I just want to
say that because there's so many Fly by
Night Renta shamans running around and
people who have done like one Yoga
Retreat and had one or two psychedelic
experiences or was suddenly acting as on
the road Messiah trying to prze everyone
and this also goes for meditation right
like I know people who have basically
had what I would call psychotic breaks
pursuing Kundalini Awakening and then
they are suddenly traveling salespeople
for endorsing this and they haven't yet
even achieved stability for themselves
this is really common so just make sure
you're dealing with people who have
handled Redline casin and have a a clear
demonstrated track record regardless of
the
modality is there anything you'd like to
add not necessarily along those lines
but any comments you'd like to make I
have I have more questions I do want to
ask about
ndes oh I forgot about that part of my
life oh I know I take notes so I don't
forget one of the things that we've
learned at cheetah house is exactly that
scenario that you're describing is that
the helper professions can also be the
source of harm and Trauma this is called
institutional betrayal when the people
who are supposed to be helping you are
actually the cause of harm then like
what happens when you have not only
trauma to meditation but trauma to all
helping professions or help helping
professionals it like really restricts
your
options yeah and so we and there's other
groups that do this
too you know we run a peer support model
because a lot of people get to the point
where they don't trust anyone until they
can sort of prove that like I was
completely undone by this I understand
what it's like to be leveled by this
scenario and then you're like okay you
get it now I can talk to you because
that empathy when when you've been
leveled that much this is like one of
the the Silver
Linings
is that you have so much compassion and
empathy when you've been leveled you
really understand what that's like to be
in that place to be a puddle on the
ground yeah so that's one of the models
that we have at cheetah house and I
think it it really works and it it works
in two ways one is that people feel
heard and validated and not alone
because they're like they're being able
to to talk to someone that this happened
to as well who's also recovered so
they're like oh my God I can actually
recover from this and then for the
people who are offering care they're
like wow I had this fiveyear hole in my
life this thing that is not good for
anything and now it's something that's
actually a gift I can give to somebody
else and so every moment that they spend
with someone else is actually sort of
being fueled by that trauma so it's nice
to be able to have that trauma mean
something and be useful
in some way and not just be a drain on
your life so that's another piece M that
I think is is a nice model that's out
there but yeah I I hear you with the
trouble finding a good therapist boy
yeah there are a lot of clowns running
around all over the place and uh just to
to underscore the peer support because
you you reminded me of something I'll
put out a plea to the Psychedelic
communities which is if you have not
this is also related to your getting
leveled comment if you have not had at
least 30 to 50 high do psychedelic
experiences you should not be
serving psychedelics to
anyone that'll be statement number one
that would be a minimum and I'm not
recommending people do anything illegal
but I'm simply saying people are going
to do what people are going to do if you
have not been tumbled and humbled in a
way that has left you questioning
whether you should ever touch these
compounds again you are not in a
position to administer to other people
and the equivalent would be if you go
skiing once on the bunny slope and you
happen not to fall and all of a sudden
you're taking people on hella skiing
trips without any type of guides or
airbags because skiing is fun and
helpful that is what I see all over the
place so step number one is 30 to 50
minimum personally because that'll give
you a chance to go skiing 50 times and
not only will you fall you will have
some bad Falls and you'll have different
types of Falls and then you'll be more
informed on a subjective level about the
risks involved and then I would say
secondly you should and this this
connects to your Pierce spor comment
volunteer with an organization like Zeno
at festivals where the age range skews
younger like lightning in a bottle and
other places Zeno is peer driven harm
reduction related to psychedelic but
really drug consumption and you get a
decent amount of training it's pretty
nominal it's non
directive support so you're not trying
to therapize people but here's what I
would
suggest is you volunteer for the
roughest shift which is generally going
to be after
midnight and if you're capable and you
should determine if you're capable
volunteer what they sometimes call the
crisis tent which is when they have
Redline cases when people are really
freaking the [__] out and losing their
minds often for hours at a time and see
how well you handle those if you don't
handle those really well you should not
be serving psychedelics to anyone so
that's my public service announcement
anyway
ndes how did you become interested in
near death experiences wow this was not
a question that deeply interested in
this I was like I wonder what part of my
website he's gonna find discover I
totally forgot about this I mean I think
you know wow this is a really long time
ago but I was really interested
in temporal lobe epilepsy uhhuh and how
people have religious experiences as a
result they call it the sacred disease
and there's been speculation that there
have been a number of saints that had
had temporal love epilepsy and so I was
really interested to know whether
near-death experiencers well I was just
really interested in the question of
whether religious experiences and
temporal lob epilepsy if there was an
overlap but near-death experiences are
actually one of the few types of
spiritual experiences that are actually
kind of similar mhm there's a typography
like there's you know there's a tunnel
there's a light there's a Life review
they're kind of similar and so that's
kind of an ideal thing to study and so
that's what I did did and I happen to
work in a sleep lab
and sleep is a natural activator of
hypersynchrony so basically epileptiform
brain activity because as you go to
sleep your brain synchronizes and so if
you tend to have epilepsy it will show
up in your sleep and so there was you
can also use strobe lights you mean to
induce epilepsy yeah hence the warnings
on all the video games right but from an
institutional review board human
subjects you know I'm going to induce
seizures in people so but like hey I'm
not doing any induction I'm just let
they're just
sleeping I don't have to tell them that
there so anyway they slept in the lab
and we we looked at their brains to see
whether they had any kind of
hypersynchrony and they did that was the
Shocker wait when you say they these are
people with diagnosed epilepsy or you're
talking about people who had n no so I
taught a class on death and loss in
graduate school
and as part of that class I kind of
inherited a lot of the guest speakers
from like other people that taught the
class and one of them was a woman who
had had a near-death experience and ran
a near-death experience support group
and I was like amazing so I went started
going to the support group and I was
like there's so many of them and then I
was like hey you guys want to come sleep
in the lab and we'll scan your brains
and see what's going on there and so I
kind of made friends with the near death
support group and that's how that stud
happened the group was I forget how many
there were but I don't know like 20 or
something like people who had had near
death experiences and then we had people
who had there were some type of
non-death experience control group I
forget if they were trauma survivors I
can't even remember far death experience
yeah um anyway we had a control group
and they did not have any kind of
epileptiform activity in their brains
how do you explain that that's so
fascinating I'm pretty agnostic as to
what that means just if you're like two
drinks in and speculating I mean there's
two possibilities one is that the they
did not have epileptiform activity and
it's a scar right it's like a residue of
the experience chances are when you have
a near-death experience and these are
people that all had their heart stop so
they definitely had some anoxia oxygen
deprivations which can cause
hypersynchrony and epileptiform activity
so that's one possib the other
possibility is
that they had a sort of tendency towards
hypersynchrony and that was what
caused the experience but you know I was
very agnostic about not choosing a
position or having an interpretation I
just said this group has a different has
a sort of distinct brain activity
compared to non-experienced and I just
left it at that but what was so
interesting was the response that I got
from both both complete Skeptics and
from the near-death
experience community so I got the total
opposite from no no interpretation on my
part and this has been actually like a
kind of thing that's followed me for my
whole life the universe Roar shock test
let's see how people take it thank you
so much for verifying and proving
scientifically with with Neuroscience
because Neuroscience can prove anything
right that heaven
exists you know and I'm like well I
don't think I really did that but thanks
I'm not sure that was in my summary yeah
and then the Skeptics would write me and
be like thank you for finally proving
that these people are all nuts you know
and I was like okay I did neither of
those things but that's
interesting and so wow I mean that's a
whole other conversation is like be a
researcher or just talk about charged
topics and see what kind of responses
you get yeah
fascinating I I I could keep going on
the ndas I have a lot of questions about
that a lot of the descriptions seem to
be incredibly similar to
the mystical experiences reported by
users of higher dose psychedelics that
the descriptions are very very similar
which is interesting because you have
this sort of fear extinguishing related
to death in both camps frequently it
seems to
be the case and I'll ask you a question
we can cut it out of the audio if you
want but I'm curious so there seem to be
and I don't think there's anything in
any peer-reviewed studies or anything
but many case
studies
of supposedly reports of people who
observe things while their hearts are
stopped or they are technically brain
dead right so conversations that are
happening things that are moving around
the tools that are used they take the
Dentures out of someone and put them on
a specific tray these types of
things is that just complete nonsense or
do you think that's something that's
worth
investigating piques my curiosity it's
funny because I have the reputation for
being the grumpiest skeptic ever and now
I'm going to tell you some mind-blowing
stories from my near-death experience
research what are you trying to do to my
reputation here Tim we don't have to
keep it but I think I know people will
be interested and I'm interested I have
to follow my own interest I'll tell you
a crazy story that happened this is true
and it happened like the the sort of end
of the story happened recently mhm I'll
tell you the end of the story first so
we want to move to Vermont and we're
building another off-grid cabin so we're
like interviewing Builders and so we
went walking around we met this Builder
and we were walking around this other
house that he built and he's just
showing you know he's showing us all the
features of this house and one of the
features was a double pane glass that
you can just like flip the switch and
like there's an opaque gas maybe you
have one of those no I don't have one
but I know the windows you're talking
about and I was like that's so awesome
suddenly this window goes you know
opaque and it's like kind of foggy mhm
and mat reminded me of this experience
that this woman had in my study she was
actually a survivor of a World War II
bombing in London so it was a very long
time
ago first of all she came back speaking
another language from her near-death
experience okay so that was the first
weird thing so I was like you know all
of these stories I was like a graduate
student and all of these stories were
very far-fetched to me and this was a
language she had not been exposed to I
don't know but I okay anyway came back
speaking other language paying that much
attention I was just like we never St
all right like okay let's see what
you're going on in your brain near death
experiencers a lot of them have life
reviews where they go through their
lives and they kind of experience the
consequences of their actions from the
perspective of who they impacted which
can be very hellish depending on what
kind of person you've been but then if
people are are sort of dead long enough
they also have flash forwards where they
actually not only see their past but
also the future so this was this was one
of the ones that was a Flash Forward and
so she told me that she basically saw
this
city and all the buildings were
basically made of this glass that
had and this is a woman she's probably
like 80 at this time she's not super
like technologically sophisticated so
she's like and she's describing this
glass that when you flip a switch you
can turn it it has some kind of gas in
between it that you can Swift the switch
and it turns into opaque and that the
future will be this glass huh and I was
like whatever okay that's so crazy
sounding and then maybe like four years
later she called me and she was like the
glass exists and she sent me to a like a
Scientific American or like discover
magazine and it was like smart glass I
think it's called she's like this isn't
the exact company so don't like invest
in it or anything but like this is the
pre to what it's going to be she's like
this is the future of what things are
going to be made out of so again like
completely sealed off that part of my
life for like I don't
know 25 years 23 years and now I just
saw the glass myself in Vermont so I
don't know I don't know I mean people
think I'm super grumpy and skeptical but
I'm just agnostic I don't know I think
just letting the mystery be there is
fine it's just doesn't need to be solved
but I I have heard crazy stories like
that I don't know what to make of it
will I be investing in Smart
Glass maybe I mean can't hurt right I
mean it could hurt depending on how much
you
invest a little a little bit little bit
might go a long way if they're going to
build cities out of
it that's amazing yeah I you know
there's part of me that with no
defensible Foundation well well I'll
leave that alone for a second but feels
like some of these ndes the high do or
they don't even need to be high do but
let's just say higher dose psychedelic
experiences and many other things some
of these meditative states are kind of
touching parts of the same thing it's
like The Five Blind Men holding on to
different parts of the elephant that
whole Parable anyway working pet Theory
without a whole hell of a lot to back it
up that would stand up to the capital S
kind of skeptic societies and so on but
still something that that sticks in my
mind
well Dr Britain this has been great I've
really enjoyed this conversation I think
it will be helpful to people and to many
who are listening probably who have had
some of
these Adverse Events or effects who have
felt very much alone and certainly I
could have
used that feeling when I was going
through what I went through at at my
Meditation Retreat is there anything
else that you would like to add people
can find cheetah house on Twitter at
cheetah house org on Facebook cheetah
house.org and Instagram cheetah. housee
uh anything that you'd like to add
before we wind to a close I mean I think
that I'd like to end just by thanking
you for being as open and and
forthcoming as you have been I don't
know if you've gotten any push back but
a number of people who share their their
negative
experiences any kind of negative
experience but particularly ones with
meditation get a lot of Kickback and
it's not it's not an easy thing to do so
I'm I'm very appreciative that you've
done that and you didn't have
to so I think it's going to be really
helpful for people and you know
especially this kind of group of people
that emulate you and you know these sort
of young male 18 to 30
demographic so in my world you're really
a hero and doing something that's that's
hard
and yeah just so I just want to say
thank you thank you I really appreciate
you saying that and it's my pleasure to
do it because by offering my story I'm
not saying meditation bad I am I I
actually find meditation and small doses
to be incredibly incredibly helpful in
my life
and that is not mutually exclusive with
also saying hey in different formats in
different doses things can go off the
rails and you need
to being a good boy or girl scout be
prepared for that and institutions and
groups and facilitators and centers need
to be prepared for that and hope is not
a strategy right it's like you get in
your car and drive with the seat Bel off
it's like that's just stupid it's like
maybe you haven't had a head on cision
but they happen every day so wear a seat
belt I mean they're basic precautions
and and I hope that will help people to
think about this in a sort of risk
informed way not so that they can say
I'm never going to meditate but simply
to know this is a possibility and to
ensure that they have support structures
around
to help them in case they run into
turbulence or something even more
Extreme as as I did and that's true for
so many things in life and I really
appreciate you doing the research you do
I'm sure you get a hell of a lot of flak
for
it and it's important to have this be
part of the conversation and it's going
to increasingly be part of the
conversation I mean you have startups
and companies that are worth billions of
dollars promoting mindfulness and medit
a you have the same thing happening in
psychedelics lots of profit motives
which is not
automatically something that begets evil
but it does beget incentives and that
means we will most certainly have tens
of thousands potentially hundreds of
thousands and millions of people
engaging with things that historically
were pretty limited to a fine slice of
the
population and we are going to see
Adverse Events you know what I promised
one other thing that I have to ask about
so how did the Dalai Lama receive your
description of your
research oh boy did you watch the video
no I didn't see the video I saw some
text about it but I did not see the
video so there is a video of me
presenting to the doll Lama as part of
the mind and life
dialogues I will let viewers make their
own decisions about what they think I
will I will tell you some feedback that
I got I mean you'll see me there if you
want to watch Willoughby in sympathetic
overload you know I was it was pretty a
pretty terrifying experience in general
so I don't really remember the feedback
as it was happening cuz I was a little
bit like out of my my body probably but
I got there were a lot of people there
the entire like mind and life board was
there and so they gave me some
feedback a lot of people found his
response fairly dismissive
and
also a
bit not particularly compassionate like
he was laughing half the time and I was
like well did I tell you that the
duration of impairment was 3 years and
also the people that it happened to were
some of our best and brightest
meditation teachers name any meditation
teacher that you can name who's written
Dharma books like he was probably in our
study and he probably had a meditation
related Challenge and the Dal Lama was
basically saying that this happened to
people because they didn't have enough
Buddhist training you know and it was
like I don't know so I don't know you're
not really supposed to talk [__] about
the dolly Lama so you might want to cut
this one out but no people need to grow
up come on I wasn't particularly
impressed um if you're allowed to say
that oh it's fine like I just think
people need to grow up it's like if you
have externalized your agency into
someone view you view as a God you're
setting yourself up for trouble and I
think like I'm not a Dalai Lama expert
I'm sure that he has and demonstrably
has has offered a lot to the world but
doesn't mean he's infallible right my
husband was like he's the doll Lama he
was brought up from like age zero until
however old he is now to defend
Buddhism what do you expect so I think
that's a pretty good answer and also
it's very emblematic of it's possible
that certain teachers have never heard
of any problems because why would you
tell them that yeah you never want to be
the one that's failing the practice that
they're giving you or telling them that
that that the practice that they gave
you is harming you like that would
that's just not even like a possibility
so yeah it is what it
is I left it up there as sort of a
historical marker but I didn't refer you
to it because it's it's kind of a mixed
bag all right so boys and girls out
there be safe measure twice cut once and
thank you Willoughby so much for the
time I really have enjoyed this I think
it will be valuable for people and at
the very least it's going to spark
conversation so I'm going to get a ton
of [__] I'm fine with it because I think
this is
important
and for people listening you'll find
links to everything the resources we've
mentioned any books Etc people and so on
in the show notes as per usual at tim.
Blog podcast and until next time be a
little Kinder than is necessary not just
to others but to
yourself I'll quote Jack cornfield
actually and I'm going to paraphrase
here but if your compassion does not
include yourself then it is incomplete
and part of being compassionate now this
is my voice is making sure you account
for risks and not live in fear but
certainly live informed so until next
time everyone thank you for tuning
in